today we're going to spend most of the
time inside the tool itself
this is going to be jam-packed with lots
of vs code goodness
i'll start with showing some small
quality of life tips and tricks
and then i'll go into showing a demo of
some of the latest
github integration that we've added and
then finally i'll do an overview of what
remote development is and i'll show a
demo of one of the extensions
so the very first tip is vs code
insiders
you'll notice i have two versions of vs
code on my desktop here and i'm using
the one with the green icon
or the vs code insiders build
this is the one our team uses to
actually work on vs code
so it's straight from master you're
going to be using the hottest bits
if you use insiders you get a lot of the
latest features that are still
in preview or things that we're
experimenting with that we would like
feedback on and if you find a bug or an
issue
and you report it we can typically get
that fix within a day or two so it's a
really fast turnaround
you can have both installed side by side
the stable version
and insiders they are isolated from each
other and you can go to
code.visualstudio.com insiders to
install it
now let's go on to the next part of
customizing the editor
i think the best part of vs code is that
it is extensible and flexible
to however you like to code or whatever
your productivity
workflow or style is with extensions and
settings
even the layout there is just so much
ways to customize
vs code so my vs code will look
different from your vs code
and that's totally fine right we want vs
code to work the way
that all developers work so some of the
most important
shortcuts and things to remember the
first one
is the command palette so every action
that you do
in vs code can basically be mapped to a
command
if you are on windows it's ctrl shift p
or if you're on a mac it's command shift
p
or you can use f1 so if i do this
this opens up the command palette so if
you're ever wondering
hey i wonder how to open this part or i
wonder if vs code can do this
you can search for something that you
want to do and it'll typically show up
in here
extensions can also contribute commands
to this so for instance you see i have a
bunch that are from
like this github issues extension or i
can just
type things in so if i want to see all
the get related things i can do
there's a whole bunch of commands that
you can access from the command palette
the next pro tip is the settings so this
is going to be control
comma or command comma so if i do this
this will open up
my settings editor there are two
settings editors
in vs code both a ui which you're seeing
right now and a json
so if you prefer one or the other you
can
change the shortcut so if i search for
settings
you can see here the setting for
settings editor so i have it set to the
ui
but if you prefer json you can do this
go click that command
command comma and it'll open up your
settings editor in json
also while we're in settings if you
don't already have this turned on
you definitely must do this right now
search for autosave
autosave has literally saved lives
no joke this is going to save your
workflow if you don't already have this
turned on
there's different options that you can
turn on i have it on focus change so if
i
switch editors or switch my window this
is what
i prefer but also if you're a javascript
editor
a developer sorry another thing that
might be useful for you
instead of for auto save is format on
save
so you can have one or the other
typically set and this is if you're you
know using something like prettier
or some kind of formatter and you prefer
to use this every time you save it will
just format everything with your
prettier config so this is really
convenient for a lot of javascript
developers
let's go into some other quick keyboard
shortcuts that are really
going to help you when you're coding
inside the editor
so i'm open up the markdown file of this
copying line up and down so this is a
really good
tip that i really like so if you are
using a mag it's going to be shift
option
up or down um so if i do this
i can actually take each line and just
really easily
move it to the right place so this is a
really easy and important
tip that saved me a lot of time instead
of copying pasting
another one is multiple cursors this is
awesome this is going to save you so
much time
so there's different ways to do this the
one that's easy to do if you
if you prefer using a mouse is option
click so i can actually place where i
want the cursors to be
in this one
or you can use shift command l and this
will actually highlight the same word
every time it's found so for instance i
can click on this
and go shift command l
and it'll highlight every instance of
the word command or customize
and then i can start working on it here
so there's different ways to use
multiple cursors
but definitely use them in your workflow
it's very very helpful
and now let's go into showing you how to
customize your vs code layout
so first thing you can do is actually
move around things
in the activity bar and sidebar a lot of
people don't know you can do this
you can move icons around that you get
from different extensions
you can right click and also hide
different you know extensions icon so
you can make your activity bar a little
bit cleaner if you want
same with the status bar you can choose
to hide things or show things however
you want
but one of the latest things that we've
done inside vs code is actually
help you customize your layout a little
bit more
so if you do control or command
tilde or sorry backtick this is going to
open up a terminal
so we want to give you more freedom to
be able to move things between the
terminal and
this sidebar over here so when you have
all this open it can be a little bit
much
and maybe you want to move different
views to different places based on
your preferred workflow so for instance
if i wanted to
maybe take the search panel over here
and move it into
my bottom view i can do that now
and now i get the same search
functionality
still works still does the same thing it
would if it was in the other place
and i can also do the vice versa so if i
want to maybe take the debug console
here
and maybe move it inside my debug view
i can do that too it's really sweet it's
really easy
helps you really totally customize and
take control of your
editor and say maybe you are moving
things around experimenting and maybe
you
maybe set something to a different
location you can just right click on the
view
and reset the location or you can search
for the command
reset view and it does the same thing so
now everything's back to where
it was another pro tip is
i've heard from a lot of users that they
actually prefer this sidebar to be
on the right side and not on the left
side
so you can go to view appearance
and you can move the sidebar to the
right
and some people prefer this because when
they actually
toggle this it will not actually move
their code
or their editor but if it's on the right
if it's on the left side it will
so i can move it bar back to the left
and this actually moves your code which
it can be a little bit jarring
so these are some really quick and easy
pro tips on customizing your editor
customizing your keyboard shortcuts
making use of them to really be
productive inside vs code
and next i'll go into showing some
github related features
all right let's talk github so on the vs
code team we want to make you as
productive as possible
when we talk to developers we often hear
things like there's so much context
switching
so for instance when i move from all my
tabs i have open on github and back to
my code
i lose track of a lot of things i lose
time i lose focus
so we want to make the stuff that you do
on github closer to you
inside your editor we want to bring the
outer loop
a lot of the collaboration you know
documentation
stuff that you do on github closer to
where you're actually writing your code
so that there is less context switching
you're not jumping around as much and
you can be more
focused and productive
so one of the extensions that you
definitely need to have installed if
you're working with github in any
capacity
is the github pull requests and issues
extension
so i can search for it inside the
extension marketplace it's the one
that's published by github
so this lets you create and manage
comment on and merge
pull requests from inside vs code and
most recently
we also added support to let you work
with issues as well
so once you have this installed it's
going to contribute this
icon to the activity bar and it's going
to ask you to sign in so you have to do
that once
so now i'm going to open up a new window
so we wanted to make it really easy for
anyone to get started with github as
well
so this is a totally empty project it's
an empty window
i'm going to clone a repository so
because i've signed
in with the github pull request
extension
it's going to leverage that and let me
clone from github
so you can see here this populated a
list of all the repos that are
actually associated with me on my github
profile this is really neat really
convenient for me to be able to
just clone a repository but i can also
search for any
anything on github so for instance if i
wanted to maybe work
on a react project i could do that i
could just search for create react app
all right let's clone that to my local
machine
you can see here vs code is doing that
real quick let's open in a new window
and i have it installed right that was
really easy normally with
cloning something you have to go to
github you know get the link
bring it in your terminal do all that so
we want to make it super super easy for
you
to get started so if i open up my
terminal let's just check if everything
worked out all right so vs code cloned
it
and set up my remotes for me over https
this is really easy um great to get
started with
great to just do it from inside your
editor if you want to
all right i want to show some more
really cool things the
github extension lets you do inside vs
code so i've opened up a folder
with a project i have called taskrunner
and this is a vs code extension
that lets you view npm you know whatever
tasks you have
inside your project so let's work on
this and show off how to use the pull
requests and issues view
so i can go to this github view over
here and you can see i have two sections
for my pull requests and issues
so i can click on this and it'll
actually just show me all
of the open pr's i have and i can also
have them
in the specific categories with these
specific filters
so we have one and i can open it up and
view the description of this and this
view should look really similar
to what it is on github you can
check out the branch we heard that this
was something that a lot of
developers didn't do as often as they
wanted to because
there's just so many commands with get
fetch and git add this just lets you
check out the pr branch and test it out
yourself
you can go into and view the actual diff
so this is really neat lets you view the
diff if i want to change
how i view the diff i can toggle the
view from this split one
to an inline whatever you prefer
if i want to i can add a comment looks
good to me
and just leave that and start a review
or just add a single comment
and then i can also use different ways
to merge the pr so you can create a
merge commit or you can use squash or
rebase whatever you prefer to do
so this is a really easy way to make
collaboration
and bring it back into the editor if i
wanted to i can also
assign reviewers that have worked in
this repository with me
or assigned labels to this pr as well
i can also get really good integration
with issues so if you're working in a
repository where
you maybe track feature requests or bug
fixes
on issues you can do that from inside
the editor
so by default there'll be two categories
here listed my issues that have been
assigned to me and then issues that i've
created
so if you want to customize this a bit
further and actually keep track of more
specific
maybe labels or more specific things
that you've been
like assigned with keywords you can you
can do that
so i'm going to click on this pencil
here and it's going to open up the
settings
for this extension and you can see here
all the queries i'm using to populate
this list
so for instance if you prefer to keep
track of
issues with a certain keyword or the
certain label we can do that
so let's add one and maybe let's call it
feature requests
and we can add the query the query
syntax is the same as the one
as you would use on github and we've
also added in a couple of these
variables
um because we we can do that now in vs
code so let's
do the current repository that i own
this is my repository and i'm going to
do
the label feature request because that's
what i use
for incoming issues like that
and now i get that as well so this is
really all about
making it really easy for you to see and
keep track of and not
lose all the different issues or things
that have been assigned to you
so we can also just create issues and
not just manage them from this extension
so if i go back
to my readme this is where i
sort of keep track of all the upcoming
to-do's i have for my project
so let's add one here
add a to do to get user tests running
because i've been wanting to do that for
a while
so the cool thing you see here is there
was a light bulb that popped up when i
did the to do comment
so this will give me a suggestion to
create an
issue based on this to do comment
trigger but better yet i can actually
create the issue
and also assign it to someone so if i
click on at
i get a list of all the people that have
worked on my project with me
that are on this repo and i can assign
it to someone so let's assign it to me
this is something i've been wanting to
do
and then let's create the issue get user
test running perfect
all right and that's what i did it
created an issue over here so if i hover
over this
it gave me the issue number i can click
on it go back to it on github
and i can also view it now from the same
view i saw earlier so my issue is this
is the new one assigned to me
it's ready for me to work on really
convenient really easy
i can click on this arrow and start
working on it so now you see i have
switched over to a new branch for me to
work
on this issue and
you can change these settings again from
your settings so json if you don't want
to
open up a new branch you can do that you
can choose whatever you want
say i made a quick change let's make the
fix
i can go over to my source control view
and it'll actually
autofill the commit message for me and
it'll close the issue when i
check it in so this is again really sort
of closing the loop
you can open up an issue search through
issues and then start working on them
and just close them
from inside vs code no need for context
switching
making it really easier to bring that
outer
developer loop closer to where you are
writing your code
so install this extension today it's
really awesome really convenient
and now i'm going to go into a demo of
the remote containers extension
let's talk remote development so we
started working on
remote development extensions inside vs
code about a year and a half ago
so well before the impacts of
coronavirus
and the work from home situation that
many of us are in right now
back then we were talking to lots of
developers and seeing more and more of
them
developing remotely we talked to
companies that had
like huge mono repos that maybe didn't
even fit on a laptop and so developers
would just connect to a really
huge dev vm and nothing was really on
their local
box and they were able to just deploy
changes um and fixes with the vm in a
couple minutes
we've also seen more and more that data
scientists are
leveraging really specialized vms that
have
lots of gpu um so that they can you know
run
sessions on all their huge data sets and
train all their data
so we see that remote development is now
like the norm for many developers and
especially given our remote
work environments we're doing a lot of
that now so we saw that existing remote
experiences for development weren't that
great maybe you were using
remote desktop which can be a bit laggy
or you were sshing
into a vm and using the terminal and vim
so we wanted to bring
a better development experience to the
remote environment that you were
working in so we created four key remote
extensions
to be able to work for different
scenarios remote development inside a
virtual machine
inside a container inside wsl and most
recently
inside the browser we wanted you to be
able to develop in the context of the
remote host
but still have the richness of your vs
code experience
so what we did was split the vs code
into two components
into a ui component which would run on
your local machine
and a server component which would let
you edit
and run and debug your code on the
remote machine
basically the vs code server can be run
anywhere else
and the remote extensions would let you
communicate between
vs code and the server so i'm going to
show you the remote containers extension
and this lets you develop in docker
containers which if you really just
think about
is kind of like another vm the power
really comes from this
ability to create an isolated reusable
dev sandbox that you can reuse and share
with others
all the remote extensions work in a
similar way
so they will install this vs code server
component in
any one of these remote contacts so we
can search for this
remote development extensions
so if you search for this you can see
this extension
pack which comes with all three the
remote wsl
containers and ssh and then you can
separately search for the
extension that lets you work inside the
browser so this is called visual studio
code spaces
i'm going to show off containers so when
you have installed the extension pack
it's going to contribute an icon to the
very bottom of your
window here and we're going to try a
sample
so before i do this let's talk a bit
more about what is going to happen
if you like to dabble in projects you
know that sometimes you have
dependency conflicts different package
versions different versions of node
or for instance if you want to you know
clone an open source project
and and contribute but you realize that
to be able to build a project you need
something like rust or cbos plus
i have no idea how to install any of
that and to be honest
i don't know if i want to because i feel
like i'm going to mess up my machine
or maybe install the wrong compiler or
install the wrong package manager
this happens to a lot of us so we wanted
to make that easier
to work with the remote containers
extension you need to have
docker installed and you see i already
have it running
so let's open up my local terminal to
see what i have on my machine right now
open up my terminal let's type in to see
what version of node we have
okay i have an older version of node so
let's use the remote containers
extension to help us
basically create a sandbox where i can
use a specific version
of my tools and not actually have to
worry about messing anything up on my
local machine
so i'm going to try a sample remote
containers
and i'm going to try the node sample
so this is going this is a set of
repositories that we've
already built for you just to try out
what it's like to use this
it's going to build an image but i
already built it once so it's just going
to connect to the container now
alright so you see here that vs code
pretty quickly connected
to this container
you see on the bottom left here that i'm
inside this dev container
so let's see what that really means this
terminal looks a little different
all right it looks like i'm on a linux
terminal i'm inside of a new
environment this is different from my
local environment i'm on a mac right now
let's see what version of node i have
all right i have a
updated version of node for me to use so
what happened
instead of running on my local machine i
am now running
inside this container i'm running vs
code inside this docker container if
you're not familiar with docker it's a
way for you to
encapsulate environments from the os
down
and it lets you build more specific
things and layers on top of it
so the magic here is really inside this
dev container
so i have this docker file this is
you know a really standard docker file
i'm not really doing anything fancy here
vs code also doesn't really um interfere
and
get involved here it's just telling
docker hey go build this and run the
container
so once the container is building then
we're going to inject a version
of the vs code server in the container
not the ui
just the vs code server just the things
that give you
language support debugging support
things like that
and now there's a connection between my
local client that's running my ui so you
see here i i still have
the same vs code theme i had on my local
machine so i'm running my
ui locally but i've connected to this
container
so now the magic is in this
devcontainer.json
this tells vs code how to set up my
container for me to be able to develop
like i do locally
so it's going to tell it's going to
point it to the dockerfile i want
and it's going to set settings so i can
choose that
i want a bash terminal inside this
environment that i want these specific
extensions i have the es lint extension
installed
so you can see here there's a difference
between the extensions i have
inside my container and inside my local
computer and i can also list
ports to forward so that i can connect
to them locally
so let's try running this let's just see
what happens right this is a standard
express app
i'm going to open up the main file this
is just an express app
you see i still get a lot of the
colorization
if i wanted to i get you know the the
autocomplete
things like this that i'm used to i can
get linting i can get errors
this is all things that i can do i can
set breakpoints
so let's just run it f5 see what happens
all right it's running on this local
address and i'm able to connect to it
like how can i actually connect
to this address from my you know local
edge browser
like this is the magic of remote
development
you saw in the dev container that i set
up the ports i wanted to forward
you know containers are isolated so if i
wanted to access anything from inside
the container i needed to forward it
so i can access it for my local host so
i didn't have to set up anything for
this to work right we are now
in a specific environment for me with a
specific version of my tools
i didn't have to set anything up besides
installing the containers extension and
having docker installed
so this is really really cool right like
think about all the cases that this
could be used for
it's really great for onboarding people
that are new to your team
so you know we all know adding a new
engineer to our team is expensive they
spend
two weeks trying to figure out how to
set up their computer you
have to teach them how to run you know
the build tools show them really
specific things to your
team's environment but instead you could
encode this all in a docker file
no you don't have to spend weeks reading
through all the giant steps in your
readme
you don't have to pollute your machine
or install the wrong version of
something
you just pull any project that has a dev
container
so vs code knows how to connect to it
and you can just build and connect to
the container
you can also specify the vs code setup
inside the dev container
this is also really awesome for maybe
the education scenario think about
students learning to code
in their first computer science class so
many of them get discouraged because
they don't know how to
you know install java and the jdk and
their ide at home
but if you encapsulate all the
dependencies and set up
inside just a docker container that's
all they need to know
so i really want to thank everyone for
joining us this was an awesome
awesome event i'm glad you were all here
at openjs
so install the containers extension
install the github extension give us
feedback on
what else you want to see from vs code
and i hope you have a great rest of your
day
thank you